SENATE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US FOR THIS MEETING OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WE WELCOME THE
PUBLIC IN PERSON, AND WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE Þ STREET BUILDING.
WE ONLY HAVE ONE BILL ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. SO I ASK ALL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE BE PRESENT IN ROOM
2200 SO WE CAN ESTABLISH OUR
QUORUM AND BEGIN OUR HEARING.
THIS ITEM IS BEING CONSIDERED
UNDER SENATE RULE 2910. BE OUR
COMMITTEE HEARD THIS MEASURE
PREVIOUSLY, BUT IT WAS
SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED ON THE
FLOOR. SO THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE HAS REFERRED THE BILL
TO US TO HEAR THOSE CHANGES. AS
I LOOK AROUND, WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM. SO WE WILL OPERATE AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. IT'S OKAY. WE HAVE
THE AUTHOR, ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WILSON. WELCOME. GOOD MORNING.
AND GOOD MORNING. JUST TO
REMIND, WE HAVE, IF NEEDED, TWO
LEAD WITNESSES, TWO MINUTES
EACH, AND WE WILL HAVE SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION AFTER YOUR
PRESENTATION. WELCOME. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS, EVEN THOSE WHO ARE
UNLIKELY TO SUPPORT. VERY HAPPY
THAT WE GOT. YES. OPEN MIND AND
THE MIND. I APPRECIATE THAT,
REALLY, I'M VERY PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 3259 BEFORE YOUR
COMMITTEE ONE MORE TIME, IT IS
PRIMARILY A DISTRICT BILL,
PROVIDING NEEDED CLARITY AND
FLEXIBILITY FOR VOTERS IN SOLANO
COUNTY TO RAISE LOCAL REVENUE AS
THE CHAIR NOTED, THE AMENDMENTS
SINCE YOU SAW IT LAST TIME,
SIMPLY ADD TWO OTHER CITIES THAT
ARE SEEKING THE SAME FLEXIBILITY
CITY OF PINOLE AND THE CITY OF
CAMPBELL. THEY BOTH, AS WELL AS
AN URGENCY CLAUSE NEEDED FOR THE
INITIATIVES APPEARING ON THE
BALLOT IN NOVEMBER AND OTHER
TECHNICAL CLARIFYING CHANGES.
BOTH OF THESE CITIES ARE IN
SIMILAR POSITIONS TO THE CITY OF
BENICIA AND DO NEED THIS BILL.
SPECIFICALLY, THIS BILL WOULD
RAISE THE STATUTORY TRANSACTION
AND USE TAX LIMIT ABOVE THE 2%
CAP TO ALLOW CITIES WITHIN THE
AFOREMENTIONED JURISDICTIONS TO
VOTE ON MEASURES THAT RAISE
LOCAL REVENUE AT A RATE NOT TO
EXCEED 0.5%. WITH A SUNSET IN
2029. NOW BOTH THE CITIES OF
PINOLE AND CAMPBELL, JUST LIKE
THE CITY OF BENICIA, HAVE SALES
TAX MEASURES ON THE BALLOT IN
NOVEMBER. THIS IS AFTER GAUGING
COMMUNITY SUPPORT AND RECEIVING
OVERWHELMING SUPPORT, WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS NICOLA. NICOLA
LÀ. I'M SORRY. I'M GOING TO MESS
IT UP, EVEN THOUGH I KNOW YOUR
NAME. NICOLA DELUCIA. ON BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF CAMPBELL AND
PINOLE, GOOD MORNING, HONORABLE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
NICOLO DELUCA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF PINOLE AND CAMPBELL, I
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS EXTREME
GRATITUDE FOR THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR INCLUDING US INTO
THIS BILL. AND OF COURSE, YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THEIR
HARD WORK. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES? YES JUST A
QUICK SUPPORT. KAREN LANG, ON
BEHALF OF THE SOLANO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. I DIDN'T
GET HERE THE FIRST TIME, SO JUST
THANK YOU. IN SUPPORT AND
APPRECIATE IT. OKAY. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT OF AB 3259 SEEING
NONE. IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB 3259 OKAY.
SEEING NONE. QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. WE HAVE A LOT OF TIME
SO YOU CAN YOU CAN ASK ALL THE
QUESTIONS YOU WANT. WE COULD WE
COULD TALK ABOUT ALMOST
ANYTHING. THE AFOREMENTIONED
TREATISE THAT ONE OF OUR
COLLEAGUES ACCUSED ME OF DOING
THAT. OH NO, OH NO NO NO NOT NO
NO. IT WAS A DIATRIBE. NOT A
TREATISE. OKAY, WELL, QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, ANYTHING CONCERNS. YOU
KNOW WHAT? I'LL DO? I'LL MAKE A
COUPLE. OKAY. SO WE'RE NOT
FLYING BLIND. AND YOU KNOW WHY I
STAND WHERE I STAND? YEAH. SO,
YOU KNOW, THESE, OVER THE YEARS,
THERE'S BEEN AN INCREASE IN
THAT, THAT PERCENTAGE THAT WHEN
YOU BUY A HOUSE AND THEY GIVE
YOU YOUR TAX BILL, YOU KNOW, YOU
HAVE YOUR 1% AD VALOREM, AND
THEN YOU HAVE ALL THE REST OF
THE STUFF AND TRADITIONALLY IT'S
BEEN PEOPLE HAVE TRIED TO KEEP
THAT UNDER THE 2% MARK, BECAUSE
IT BECOMES UNAFFORDABLE. THAT
BECOMES THE UNAFFORDABILITY FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO BUY A
HOUSE. AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN
THE MIDST OF TRYING TO GIVE
PEOPLE DOWN PAYMENTS AND ON
REALLY EXPENSIVE HOUSES STILL.
AND SO THEY'RE REALLY ON THE
BRINK OF NOT BEING ABLE TO DO
THAT, AND IN THE MEANWHILE,
WE'RE KIND OF ENABLING, YOU
KNOW, IT'S KIND OF LIKE STUDENT
LOANS. THE MORE STUDENT LOANS
YOU GIVE PEOPLE, THE MORE THE
EVERYBODY CHARGES FOR
EVERYTHING. AND SO WE'RE PILING
COSTS INTO ALL THE HOUSING AND
THE STUFF THAT WE'RE DOING OUT
THERE, YOU KNOW, CSDS AND CFDS
HAVE BECOME THE CLEARINGHOUSE
FOR ALL FEES RELATED TO
BUILDING. AND, AND SO THAT TURNS
WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A 10,000 OR
$20,000 SHARE FOR THAT
PARTICULAR RESIDENT, OR
RESIDENTIAL UNIT INTO A LONG
TERM 30 YEAR BOND THAT THEY'RE
PAYING UP TO, YOU KNOW, 2 OR 3
TIMES AS MUCH FOR. AND ALL OF
THOSE COSTS ARE PART OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO CALIFORNIA IN TERMS
OF BEING TOO EXPENSIVE. WE DO A
LOT OF THINGS THAT ARE ARE
OPTIONAL AND VOLUNTARY, AND WE
MAKE THEM MANDATORY COSTS, AND
THAT RAISES THE PRICE. AND THEN
IT NECESSITATES, YOU KNOW,
CITIES HAVING TO GO TO THE WELL,
WHICH IS THEIR TAXPAYERS. AND
THERE'S ONLY SO MANY, SO MUCH
MONEY OUT THERE FOR THOSE
TAXPAYERS THAT BEFORE THEY
FINALLY CRACK AND THEY START
MOVING, AND WE'VE ALREADY SEEN
THAT. AND, YOU KNOW, I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE BEFORE WE RESORT TO
THAT TO, TO TELLING PEOPLE, HEY,
WE NEED MORE MONEY FROM YOU. I
WOULD LIKE US TO BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE FRUGAL ON HOW WE HOW WE
SPEND AND HOW WE DETERMINE, YOU
KNOW, WHAT COSTS ARE GOING TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH BUILDING A HOME
OR BUILDING A STREET OR BUILDING
ANYTHING, IT COSTS THREE TIMES
AS MUCH TO BUILD A ROAD HERE AS
IT DOES IN ARIZONA. AND YOU GOT
TO ASK OURSELVES WHY. AND THE
ANSWER CAN'T BE, WELL, WE'LL
JUST KEEP EXTRACTING MORE AND
MORE MONEY UNTIL PEOPLE CAN'T
TAKE ANYMORE, AND THEN THEY
LEAVE, BECAUSE THEN WE WON'T
HAVE MORE AND MORE MONEY. WE
JUST HAVE A MOUNTAIN OF DEBT AND
NO PLACE TO GO. SO THOSE ARE MY
CONCERNS WITH THIS APPROACH. AND
UNTIL I SEE THE STATE IN
GENERAL, BE BETTER AT COST
CONTAINMENT ON OUR SIDE, IT'S
HARD FOR ME, EVEN IN A DIFFERENT
DISTRICT. AND I REALIZE THIS IS
A DISTRICT, BILL. YEAH, BUT EVEN
ANOTHER DISTRICT TO CONDONE WHAT
I THINK IS ACTUALLY ADDING TO
THE PROBLEM OF AFFORDABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I'M GLAD I WAS
ABLE TO EXPLAIN THAT IT'S NOT
JUST AN AUTOMATIC NO FOR
NOTHING. RIGHT. THAT'S IT HAS
SOME REASONING BEHIND IT. AND
WHILE SOME PEOPLE MIGHT NOT
THINK IT'S A GREAT REASONING, IT
IT IS MY REASONING BASED ON MY
EXPERIENCE AND WATCHING AND
WATCHING PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT
STRUGGLE WITH EVEN, YOU KNOW,
LOWER TAXES THAN THAT. SO NOW IT
LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE WHAT YOU
NEED YESES, YESES AND GIVE IT
RIGHT BACK TO THE CHAIR, IF IT'S
OKAY THROUGH THE CHAIR TO VERY
QUICKLY BECAUSE WE HAVE WE
ACTUALLY NEED TO DO THE QUORUM.
YEAH, THAT'D BE GREAT. AND THEN
YOU CAN CLOSE. OKAY. SOUNDS
GOOD. SENATORS DURAZZO HERE.
DURAZZO. PRESIDENT SUHARTO HERE.
SUHARTO. PRESIDENT. DOLLY.
DOLLY, PRESIDENT. GLAZER.
SKINNER. SKINNER. PRESIDENT
WAHAB. WAHAB. PRESIDENT. WIENER,
YOU HAVE A QUORUM. GREAT. NOW
THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM, WE COULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. SO MOVED.
OKAY AND, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I WOULD I
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS FROM,
MY COLLEAGUE, THE SENATOR, AND I
AGREE WITH QUITE A BIT OF THEM.
AND I DO THINK WE ARE STRUGGLING
WITH AS A STATE AFFORDABILITY
OVERALL. AND WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THE BASE THAT
THESE TAXES ARE BUILT ON, AND
THAT IS THE REQUIREMENT OF EVERY
SINGLE LEGISLATOR, NO MATTER
WHICH HOUSE YOU'RE IN, TO BE
ABLE TO FOCUS ON THAT, BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO MAKE CALIFORNIA MORE
AFFORDABLE SO THAT PEOPLE WHO
GROW UP HERE CAN STAY HERE, AND
SO EVERYTHING THAT I CAN DO
WITHIN THE TENURE THAT I HAVE,
IF THE VOTERS ALLOW ME TO
CONTINUE TO STAY, WILL BE ABOUT
DRIVING DOWN THOSE COSTS.
BECAUSE IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. AND, YOU KNOW, MY
BACKGROUND IS IN BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION, FINANCE,
BUDGETING, YOU KNOW, I CARE
ABOUT THOSE. IT'S INTERESTING
THAT THIS TIME I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON THE BOND,
WHICH IS DAD, AND WORK ON THESE
TAXES, TAXES, WHICH IS TAX. AND
IT'S USUALLY THOSE ARE TWO
THINGS I SHY AWAY FROM, BUT
THEY'RE EXTREMELY CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. AND ESPECIALLY THIS
THIS EMPOWERS THE COMMUNITIES TO
BE ABLE TO GO TO THEIR VOTERS
AND SAY, DO YOU WANT TO INCREASE
YOUR TAXES, TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
CARE OF A COMMUNITY NEED? IN THE
CASE OF THE CITY OF BENICIA,
THEY'VE ALREADY TAXED
THEMSELVES, AND THIS IS A VOTER
INITIATIVE TAX. IT'S NOT EVEN
THE CITY. THE CITY HAD ALREADY
DID IT. AND NOW THE VOTERS HAVE
COME FORTH AND THE SAME THING IN
PINOLE AND CAMPBELL. THESE ARE
THINGS WHERE THERE HAS BEEN
BROAD SUPPORT, BUT THEY ARE
LIMITED. AND SO THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO HELP
THEMSELVES, WHICH IS SOMETHING
WE DEFINITELY WANT. AND I HOPE
THAT WE'LL HAVE SUPPORT TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE THIS, ENDEAVOR
FOR CITIES TO TAKE MATTERS INTO
THEIR OWN HANDS, TO ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE ABLE TO MEET THE
SERVICES THAT THEIR COMMUNITY
REQUIRES. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. GREAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THE MOTION HAS BEEN MADE
BY SENATOR SKINNER. OH, I'M
SORRY, SENATOR SKINNER. THANK
YOU. I KNOW WE WERE. I JUST
WANTED TO GET IN SOME COMMENT
BEFORE, I KNOW THERE WAS SOME
DISCUSSION BY OUR, COLLEAGUE
HERE, SENATOR SEYARTO, ABOUT
COST OF LIVING AND SUCH, BUT
THIS IS DOES REQUIRE VOTER
APPROVAL. AND AS HAS BEEN
POINTED OUT BY THE AUTHOR, THE,
IN MANY CASES, THE OR IN CERTAIN
OF THE CITIES AND THE COUNTY
THAT WHERE THIS IS GOING TO
AFFECT THE VOTERS HAVE ALREADY
AFFIRMED THEIR INTEREST. AND
AGAIN, TO CONTINUE TO IMPOSE
ANYWHERE ELSE, THE VOTERS WOULD
HAVE TO AFFIRM, AND I THINK THIS
IS A VERY LEGITIMATE, ACTION FOR
US TO TAKE TO GIVE THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT RIGHT, AND TO
GIVE THE VOTERS THE ABILITY TO
APPROVE, IS IN MY DISTRICT, AND
THEY ARE, VERY EAGER TO SEE US
DELIVER THIS FOR THEM. AND
THAT'S WHY I MADE THE MOTION AND
WHY I SUPPORT THE BILL. AND
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SINCE
WE'VE OPENED IT UP AGAIN, I HAVE
ONE ADDITIONAL COMMENT. GO
AHEAD. SENATOR THANK YOU, YOU
KNOW, THERE ARE OTHER WAYS OTHER
THAN A SALES TAX MEASURE OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, TO BE ABLE
TO GET A COMMUNITY BUY IN AND
THAT'S THROUGH ASSESSMENTS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. YOU PUT AN
ASSESSMENT ON THE BALLOT. IT
DOESN'T TAKE THIS. THE CITIES
CAN DO THAT, DO IT THAT WAY, AND
IT DOESN'T COUNT TOWARDS THE 2%,
AND IT ALLOWS THEM TO DO THAT.
SO THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING IS
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS BESIDES
BLOWING PAST THE 2% ON OUR MARCH
TO THREE AND 4%. RIGHT? SO
THAT'S THAT'S MY POINT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO BOTH SENATORS.
THANK YOU. THE MOTION IS TO
RETURN THE BILL TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR DURAZZO I
DURAZZO. I CIERTO CIERTO. NO.
DOLLY DOLLY. NO. GLAZER.
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. WAHAB.
WAHHAB. AYE WIENER. 3 TO 2.
OKAY, THE BILL WILL GO ON CALL.
THAT'S IT. OKAY. WE WILL END. I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN TODAY'S PUBLIC
NÓ Þ ON RECESS. OKAY. SORRY.
WE'RE ON RECESS. THANK YOU.
RESUMING THE HEARING, CALL THE
MOST RECENT MEMBER MOTION IS
THAT THE MEASURE BE RETURNED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONSIDERATION. CURRENT VOTE IS 3
TO 2, WITH CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS GLAZER WIENER WIENER.
AYE, 42. OKAY. THANK YOU.
SENATOR. THE BILL IS OUT, BUT DO
YOU WANT TO PUT IT ON CALL FOR
SENATOR? HE'S NOT COMING OKAY.
YEAH. THE BILL IS OUT. NO, IT'S
NOT OKAY. THE BILL IS OUT. CLOSE
THE ROLL. CLOSE THE ROLL, THANK
YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY. IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY, PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US,
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO THE STAFF. WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA, THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS
ADJOURNED.